when Marnie was there is quite possibly
Studio Ghibli's last film at least for
sure it is their biggest break in
filmmaking right now there is no
official word on whether or not Studio
Ghibli will ever make a movie again if
you don't know who they are these guys
have produced hands-down some of the
best animated films of all time we're
talking about the studio that Hayao
Miyazaki worked out of we're talking
about My Neighbor Totoro Princess
Mononoke castle in the sky the wind
rises spirited away the tale de Princess
Kaguya so many great films and if this
really is their last film I'm devastated
because it's one of their best this film
tells the tale of a very introverted
girl who has a tough time making friends
she's had a very rough childhood and
she's staying with some family friends
for the summer and she becomes entranced
with this old mansion surrounded by
marsh
she keeps finding herself drawn to it
she wants to walk towards it she wants
to sketch it in her notepad and when she
sees the form of a young blond girl
named Marni in the window the film
starts to present a beautiful mystery a
beautiful friendship
and one of the most heart-wrenching
stories I've ever seen in an animated
film this is without a doubt one of the
best movies I've seen so far this year
it will be on my best of the year list I
guarantee it it's one a Studio Ghibli is
best and I'm telling you it is required
viewing if you are a fan of animation it
is so imperative that we support
filmmaking like this a film for children
that is mature that actually explores
some of the deepest darkest emotions
that a kid can go through because
American entertainment for kids is
usually yellow guys who go banana
don't get me wrong there I actually
really enjoy both despicable Me movies
and I would recommend them for kids to
have just a good fun time at a party or
something but these films at Studio
Ghibli has been making are so important
for kids to see and I implore parents
out there if you feel your kid is mature
enough for something like this show this
movie to him or her because it really
really can teach them a lot and one of
the things I loved about this movie is
that in classic Studio Ghibli fashion it
is extremely mysterious and there's this
strange otherworldly supernatural
element that's running throughout the
movie and you're always trying to figure
out what these puzzle pieces mean not
only is the animation stunningly
gorgeous and beautiful but the story
itself is very interesting it presents a
mystery that I as an adult sat there
with my mouth hanging open most of the
time because it's so hard not to be
taken by the beauty of this movie not
just in its look but in the messages
that its story holds and I won't spoil
anything but the ending of this movie
knocked me flat it knocked me out it was
stunning I was so pleased my eyes were
just welling up it was such a beautiful
movie I implore you guys out there
support this type of kids entertainment
because if I ever have kids this is
exactly the kind of stuff I want them to
see because this doesn't present the
world as this shiny glossy place filled
with superheroes this is a children's
movie for families that adults will
enjoy and kids will enjoy but it also
presents some of the realities of life
that kids need to know about and it's
also a beautiful mystery filled with
suspense and tension and character depth
and of course beautiful hand drawn
animation guys please support when
Marnie was there if you can find it in a
theater near you and I want to thank the
nightlight theater because these guys
brought this to my area as well as
giving me this gigantic thing that I
probably can't even fit in this video
but I love it it's awesome thank you
guys I'm imploring you guys honestly if
this is Studio Ghibli's last film I will
be devastated these guys are making
continuously my favorite animated movies
ever they're so great please check this
movie out guy
I have but one flaw with this movie the
only real issue that I have with it is
that it is very puzzling from time to
time and that mystery element of the
film well incredibly engrossing every
once in a while gets a little too
puzzling for its own good but once those
questions are answered it's all solved
I'm gonna give when Marnie was there and
a this is such a great movie guys I'm
telling you if you can find it in a
theater near you please go out and see
it if you've never seen a Studio Ghibli
film in your life go look it up on
Google figure out which films they are
see them they are some of the most
beautiful animated hand-drawn films ever
made guys thank you so much as always
for watching I really do appreciate it
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes